Cédric et Brunella maillot ont deux
enfants Louane et Joshua depuis moins
d'un an ils ont un nouveau membre dans
leur famille c'est Ipsos un toutou un
peu spécial car c'est un chien d'éveil
une réponse que Cédric et Brunella ont
apporté à leurs deux bambins car ils
sont chacun d'eux concernés par
plusieurs handicaps
c'était difficile au départ et je pense
comme tout le monde parce que tu as ton
monde qui s'effondre pour toi quand tu
sors de l'hôpital c'est noir et il y a
plus rien il y a pas d'espérance il y a
rien du tout et puis après au fur et à
mesure ben tu tu te dis ok ben tu sais
pas de quoi demain sera fait mais alors
du coup bah allons donner le maximum
pour le jour J pour le moment présent et
on a commencé à apprécier la vie qu'on
avait avec Louane on a focalisé sur les
bons moments qu'on avait avec elle sur
tout ce qu'elle faisait et pas sur ce
qu'elle faisait pas on a un soufflé
beaucoup de
on croit on croit en elle en fait on
croit au potentiel qu'elle a en elle on
essaie de se dire comment nous en tant
que parents on va pouvoir lui donner le
maximum pour maximiser son potentiel et
pour ne pas avoir en fait les limites
par la suite c'est de ça qu'elle est
notre projet c'est le commencement tout
ce qu'on a vécu avec Louane tout ce
qu'on a enduré tout ce que elle elle a
vécu qui nous a mis à cœur de commencer
quelque chose pour aider l'autre famille
et c'est vrai que la naissance de Joshua
la deuxième enfant notre petit garçon ça
fait 400 tuer ça leur projet c'est
l'association famille espoir son
objectif apporter un soutien en famille
qui traverse les mêmes difficultés parmi
les activités de soutien qui proposent
Ipsos leur chien d'éveil fait partie de
celle les plus originales et surtout
exclusives à la Réunion on avait entendu
parler des chiens d'assistance des
chiens d'éveil et on voulait en prendre
un pour la petite fille sauf qu'en son
saignant on s'est rendu compte qu'il
fallait en métropole
au niveau des frais de voyage et surtout
que Louane est très réglée donc on se
voyait pas partir 15 jours en métropole
donc on s'est dit
qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire pour acquérir
un chien parce qu'on était convaincu de
lasothérapie des bienfaits de l'animal
sur l'enfant
en discutant avec notre ami donc Olivier
Cosette qui est vétérinaire au tampon on
s'est dit pourquoi pas mettre pourquoi
pas former le chien nous-même leur ami
est vétérinaire comportementaliste il
décide de leur offrir un chien choisit
par ses soins pour démarrer le projet il
n'y a pas cette possibilité aujourd'hui
à la réunion très peu de famille ayant
un enfant porteur d'un handicap peuvent
bénéficier de ce type de choses donc
vraiment ce projet et est né de ça en se
disant ben on va essayer de mettre en
place toutes les structures localement
depuis l'élevage jusqu'à la production
finale du chien donc éducateur
vétérinaire comportementaliste famille
d'accueil pour arriver à offrir aux
familles réunionnaises des chiens
d'éveil pour les enfants porteurs de
handicap
Ipsos et pour eux un véritable plus à
l'accompagnement médico-social chaque
jour il participe à la stimulation des
enfants
Louane elle a les yeux qui pétillent
quand elles voient son chien au niveau
psychomothe ça lui apporte beaucoup
aussi dans pour l'appréhension elle va
ouvrir et refermer donc elle va
travailler en fait sa préhension rien
qu'en touchant les poils du chien quand
il vient la bousculer un petit peu en
lui faisant des bisous bah elle réagit
donc elle a elle aime son chien et
Joshua donc le bébé on a notre bébé il
lui c'est pareil il aime passer sa main
dans la fourrure de
Ipsos il se crée une véritable relation
sociale et bien sûr quand tout va très
très bien dans une famille
d'environnement les liens sociaux sont
parfaits mais lorsqu'il va y avoir des
tensions ou des troubles du lien social
et bien souvent le chien va être parce
qu'il l'a tissé un lien social aussi une
relation sociale une véritable relation
avec l'enfant l'enfant va pouvoir des
fois se confier va pouvoir lui parler va
pouvoir se rassurer donc il y a vraiment
une relation une interaction qui
intervient et qui permet à l'enfant
effectivement de puiser
parfois dans cette ressource le dressage
du chien est adapté aux enfants pour
Louane et Joshua ce compagnon fera
bientôt une parfaite nounou
ma chérie c'est bien ça
durant la première année il y aura le
assis couché pas bouger comme comme tous
les chiens la prennent et ensuite il va
rentrer dans une phase on va essayer
d'inculque d'inculquer des heures des
commandements qui sont spécifiques à
l'enfant par exemple la Louane elle elle
ne parle pas elle marche pas elle tient
pas assise donc les commandants
spécifiques qu'on va essayer de faire
entrer par la suite c'est aller prendre
son biberon par exemple aller prendre ce
biberon ramener aller prendre un jeu
ramener et rester à côté de Louane pas
bouger pendant des heures s'il faut ça
plus ça pour elle est à côté et jouer
avec elle nous prend Louane nous mature
son dos le faire caresser etc maintenant
pour un enfant qui marche sera différent
ce sera l'enfant pourra jouer avec le
chien donc là les commandements qui vont
être inculqués au chien sont un peu
différents tous les chiens ne peuvent
pas chien d'éveil
psauce n'est pas choisi au hasard c'est
un chien équilibré calme et qui a été
préparé sur plusieurs lignes on pourra
voir un chien
équilibré on va dire entre guillemets il
faut déjà que l'éleveur à la base
travaille bien entendu ses lignes
génétiques avoir les chiens les plus
calmes possible entre guillemets parce
que après c'est une question d'éducation
aussi on essaie de sélectionner au
maximum les chiens les plus doux
possible
Ipsos et le fruit d'un projet global un
espoir que ce couple souhaite faire
profiter aux familles qui traversent les
mêmes difficultés
leur souhaits réunir des fonds pour
pouvoir tout simplement donner un chien
aux familles
après nous notre chien donc hipsos pour
Louane il y a on va prendre un autre
chien dans deux mois donc la portée déjà
est déjà née on va le prendre et ce
chien là en fait on va le placer chez
l'éducateur directement chez éducateur
canin pendant une dizaine de mois et
c'est l'éducateur canal qui va lui
inculquer les bases du chien et ensuite
on va le passer dans la famille cette
solidarité ces projets d'espoir c'est ce
qui a permis à Cédric et Brunella de
surmonter leurs difficultés la famille
maillot innove au travers de ce projet
canin grâce à eux les familles
réunionnaises pourront plus facilement
faire profiter leurs enfants des câlins
de ce compagnon d'éveil